i first want to talk to you about
celsius you have become uh the celsius
uh sleuth on the internet i feel like
you continue just you're all over this
what the hell is going on
yeah a lot of craziness um i mean i i
didn't i never it was never my intention
to pick a bone with a certain company or
a group of individuals
um but just kind of the events that
transpired over the last couple of
months um i mean i i follow the markets
very closely i i mean i i really enjoy
it uh and post luna collapse uh there
was increasing there was an increasing
amount of science that there were
certain you know counterparties in the
space certain companies that potentially
had some troubles i mean just
anecdotally there's you know 20 billion
dollars of stable coins that weren't
stable and that went to zero uh so a lot
of a lot of you know and that that also
promised a 20 yield right so so i had i
had some questions i had some worries
and i posted it uh back in i think may
11th uh and i said hey you know there
there might be some announcement
solvencies i wouldn't want to have any
yield on a
kind of a crypto yield product uh not
your keys not your coins
um and so you know ultimately kind of
with the events that transpired from
from that time until now
uh some of those worries you know proved
to be correct and celsius has obviously
closed its doors so you know there's
there's some a lot more things that
happened since that time but uh yeah i
mean just a lot of craziness
so when you look at celsius right now
explain what has actually transpired
there's uh nobody allowed to withdraw
their coins or transfer between accounts
but what exactly is happening
yeah so i mean essentially you had
throughout 2020 2021 you had a whole
bunch of kind of crypto a native crypto
yield products come out and these were
able to be sustained because of a lot of
the stuff we talked about like the gbtc
arbitrage uh the futures premium where
you could essentially in a risk-free
sort of way risk-free quotation marks
but in a market neutral sort of way um
kind of you know taking away
counterparty risk exchange risk etc uh
you could capture these really really
large yields that were you know kind of
unheard of thirty percent twenty percent
uh and and you know these allowed these
kind of crypto yield products to
flourish uh but because of those high
yields the demand for them grew and
because of just how market arbitrage
works the actual yields on those
arbitrage uh trades diminished greatly
to the point where you know the gbtc
premium is now a gbt discount uh that
kind of futures contango is no longer uh
trading and it's you know oftentimes
actually right now i think it's in a
backwardation so all those yield
products uh actually or those yield
strategies disappeared and so now you
have um you know a company like celsius
that is promising all these you know
huge yields that is is kind of in a
tough position and you know instead of
diminishing yields they kind of went
further and further out onto the risk
curve uh and and the
not the shady thing but the worrisome
thing about these strategies is that
it's they're super opaque and really the
risks aren't able to be quantified right
so you know luna or ust on anchor pays
20
that's a nominal yield but what you
can't account for uh is that kind of you
know there's this potential for
catastrophic loss this this you know
kind of uh left tail blow up that really
can't be quantified so i think a good
way to describe it is a lot of these
yields aren't so much yield but they're
really just selling tail risk
and that's where that's where you kind
of run into trouble and i think that's
what's happening with celsius got it and
so how do you think this ends i saw one
tweet where you said you thought they
would get liquidated walk us through the
mechanisms of uh how much bitcoin they
have where are the price levels in which
they could start to come under pressure
for liquidation
yeah so the craziest part about this
market and honestly one of the most
fascinating aspects of it all is that
you know celsius has money on uh i
believe uh maker and they have a
collateralized loan in a vault but the
the wild thing is all these levels are
completely transparent so you can see in
real time the collateral levels uh and
how much debt they have outstanding and
so the liquidation price was at 18k and
i think this was almost like kind of a
target on their back you saw i think a
lot of market makers a lot of kind of i
wouldn't call it predatory i would call
it almost like pvp market uh you know
almost capitalism at its finest right if
there's you know a liquidation level
that's known uh someone's gonna find it
but uh celsius has been depositing more
collateral they moved that liquidation
level down to 17k
and just recently i think almost 20
minutes ago they paid down 28 million of
the debt so the liquidation level is now
at 15. so uh i think there's a you know
increasing chance they don't get
liquidated i mean obviously this would
be
uh
this would be good uh overall because
unfortunately what's happening in this
real time kind of witch hunt is that
these are customer funds at risk which
is you know kind of just underscores how
crazy this all is uh depositors you know
of celsius were actually unsecured
creditors this entire time uh which is
quite unfortunate so i'm obviously
hoping they don't get liquidated but you
know it's just market forces at play do
you think this is a scam like do you
think that there's something the ferris
going on or do you think that people are
watching this all play out in uh in real
time and uh they just don't have all the
information and so uh maybe it looks bad
but isn't it bad
yeah i don't i don't think it's an
outright scam uh per se i think honestly
it's noble to attempt to build a yield
service in an emerging industry to produ
to provide financial services what i do
think is somewhat uh i guess nefarious
or somewhat uh maybe disingenuous is is
the idea that there was no risk and that
you know uh you saw celsius and some of
the kind of executives say it's
completely safe to hold your bitcoin on
here and self-custody is actually the
thing that's not that's not safe because
people lose it in self-conscious you
trust us uh when the reality is they're
taking your funds then going on d5
protocols we have getting coins
potentially um so i mean obviously not
all exchange operates like this you know
proof of reserves i think is an
increasingly needed uh kind of a needed
action in this space right um because
it's very easy to prove uh ownership to
you know transparently say hey we have
your coins they're not moving they're at
this address um so i think that's a step
in the right direction and you know kind
of the rehydration with an absolutely
scarce asset like bitcoin was always
going to end badly right so uh i think
that's
not necessarily a scam but that you know
this is why this is why you know the
toxic maximalists per se
are so toxic because they you know
they've seen this kind of train before
and they know how it ends
so when you think about it it really
ends up being a situation where uh maybe
the actions you don't think are uh
nefarious and there's kind of a good
faith effort to build a product it's
more so the marketing and the way that
it's been positioned that's the thing
that most people have a have an issue
with
yeah i i i think that's correct i mean
we've we've seen not just not bitcoin
but just through the history of money
and economics we've seen bank runs
happen we've seen fractional reserve and
rehab altercation uh you know almost
always leads to a bank run of some sorts
uh and that leads to you know somewhat
of an insolvency or or the depositors at
these institutions going belly up that's
the reason why you know for better or
worse
with central banking today as a lender
of last resort to kind of bail out these
uh these fractional reserve institutions
because you saw bank runs happen over
and over again so now we have an
absolutely scarce digital asset that you
can custody yourself with no
counterparty risk and you know just the
the lure of of lending out money uh with
yield
and paying out yields you know these
these uh kind of financial services is
very strong both from kind of a business
perspective as well as an individual
perspective you know deposit your
bitcoin and get one percent yield but
ultimately uh and the reason i was such
a loud kind of proponent of of you know
taking your coins off
uh just be very skeptical of these
things is whether it's a one percent
yield or a five percent yield you can't
really quantify what's the percent of
chance that that you lose 100 of your
asset and so i think that risk reward in
my head just didn't make any sense and
that's why you know again i was i was
tweeting from the rooftops about this
and you know trying to get everyone uh
to get their money back
got it well you've got a bunch of uh
charts and tweets here that we're going
to go through the first is this idea of
crypto contagion explain what exactly
this is
yeah so i mean this is what i tweeted
about last month um just as a heads up
there was you know i had certain things
that i was seeing with the luna debacle
you can see the stuff happening on chain
which is very interesting but this was
kind of the first uh first warning i
would say um or kind of first uh first
thing that that i thought of post luna
collapse was you know counterparty is at
risk
you know you really don't want to you
really don't want to take a chance and
unfortunately you know just just a month
later we're seeing that all play out
got it and then if we continue to uh to
look at this you talked about the not
your keys not your coins and i think
that's a key piece of this uh i saw you
know some people say hey look bear
markets teach you a couple things one is
leverage two is not your keys not your
coins describe this a little bit more in
terms of uh how important of a concept
this is for people who are new to the
industry
yeah i mean i certainly think there's
you know quality institutional grade
custodians out there uh it's definitely
improved from the mount cox days uh but
you know certain products certain
strategies are are not safe and actually
uh whether it's nefarious actors or just
uh incompetency uh you know losses
happen and so with bitcoin you have kind
of this this for the first time ever you
have a way to to hold your own assets in
a way that's
cryptographically secure uh you know
almost mathematically secure and and no
one can steal that or take that away
from you so that's a really powerful
idea i personally believe it's one of
the biggest ideas of our time uh and
it's definitely worth uh it's worth
learning about and it's worth you know
kind of implementing in a safe and
secure way because it is very secure uh
and if you do it correctly
got it and then if we go ahead and we
take a look at some of the charts you've
got ust usd
uh what's going on with ust
yeah so the next two charts here are
just kind of showing uh what led to you
know some of the questions about celsius
and solvency uh obviously you had the
the anchor ust luna debacle uh i think
from from what the you know kind of the
on-chain stuff says and and people's
analysis of celsius's wallets they made
it out relatively unscathed than usd
actually uh so kind of just fairly and
then you know the next strategy because
you know if you think about the yield
generation strategies in the crypto
market we talked about gbtc we talked
about the futures premium the next two
were
ust on the anchor protocol paying 20
that blew up the next biggest one that
celsius was also you know very very uh
you know they were they were in
implementing this trade in size was
stake ethereum so ethereum moving to
proof of stake obviously uh you know
there's some execution risk there's you
know uh in terms of a road map it could
be pushed back but users can stake their
ethereum and get and get a yield on
their native ethereum once the eventual
kind of proof-of-stake implementation uh
comes around and so there's actually
what's called liquid staking and this uh
lido protocol allows you to get uh you
get a to stake your ethereum and then
you get a staking derivative so it's
still liquid acid and so but the thing
is similar to kind of gbtc it's a
one-way redemption so you you get you
put your wreath in your steak ethe out
but there's no way to convert it back
it's locked in until till the merge of
till proof of stake but there is a
trading market and so one of the biggest
worries and this is kind of when when
the solvency issues and uh illiquidity
issues of celsius really started to ramp
up was when this tag of stake ethereum
started to break and it was less about
solvency and more about liquidity
there was a lot of big sticky holders
that i wanted to get out and there's
just not really a liquid market for it
uh so this exchange rate where it was
you know typically one to one started to
fall and is you know trading around
i think 0.94 and so this is kind of
another one of those things where
you have you know you have a company
going out on the risk term with company
with a customer funds uh and you know
you see you see these things and you
know these these very nascent defy
markets start to break and so
you know again just kind of highlighting
what went wrong here a lot of things but
ultimately i think this all kind of
shows you that some of the the the risks
and the yield that you're compensated
with you know whether it's you know ap
apy or not uh i think you know it
doesn't really doesn't really uh
correctly identify just all the risks
out there and you have to be really
aware of what you're actually you know
putting your money into